con una voz suave pero un discurso
incisivo el papa abogó una vez más por
lo que llamó la guerra de nuestro tiempo
refiriéndose a las crisis migratorias
que se presentan en todo el mundo
el pontífice regresó el domingo a la
isla griega de lesbos y se reunió con
migrantes y refugiados que intentan
llegar a europa desde la costa turca
de espaldas a la orilla el jefe de la
iglesia católica volvió a utilizar la
metáfora que ya había expuesto en 2014
ante el parlamento europeo
m diarra el mediterráneo que durante
milenios ha unido diferentes pueblos y
tierras lejanas se está convirtiendo en
un lúgubre cementerio xalapa y dio un
cambio radical en la actitud de los
países de la unión europea
y debemos mirar los rostros de los niños
que encontremos el valor de
avergonzarnos en su presencia en su
inocencia son nuestro futuro desafían
nuestras conciencias y nos preguntan qué
tipo de mundo quieren darnos él no nos
apresuremos a apartar la vista de las
impactantes imágenes de sus pequeños
cuerpos tendidos sin vida en las playas
migrantes y refugiados que anhelan la
flexibilización de políticas migratorias
la venida del papa hoy es algo que está
haciendo que todos los refugiados sean
felices porque estamos aquí no hay
alguien que piensa en nosotros y vino a
visitarnos durante la última visita del
pontífice al esbocen 2016 la isla
albergaba a 12.000 refugiados en
condiciones precarias
francisco había pedido a los europeos
que trataran con humanidad esta crisis
pero después de todo este tiempo lamento
que poco haya cambiado